[Music]
throughout the history of mankind three
little words have sent poets to the
blank page philosophers to the Agora and
seekers to the Oracles Who am I
from the ancient Greek aphorism
inscribed on the temple of apollo know
thyself to the whose rock anthem who are
you
philosophers psychologists academics
scientists artists theologians and
politicians have all tackled the subject
of identity their hypotheses are widely
varying and lack significant consensus
these are smart creative people so
what's so hard about coming up with the
right answer one challenge certainly
lies with the complex concept of the
persistence of identity which you is who
the person you are today five years ago
who you'll be in fifty years and when is
am this week today this hour this second
and which aspect of you is I are you
your physical body your thoughts and
feelings your actions these murky waters
of abstract logic are tricky to navigate
and so it's probably fitting that to
demonstrate the complexity the Greek
historian Plutarch used the story of a
ship
how are you I
as the tail goes Theseus the mythical
founder king of Athens single-handedly
slayed the evil Minotaur at Crete then
returned home on a ship to honor this
heroic feat for 1,000 years
Athenians painstakingly maintained his
ship in the harbor and annually
re-enacted his voyage whenever a part of
the ship was worn or damaged it was
replaced with an identical piece of the
same material until at some point no
original parts remained Plutarch noted
the Ship of Theseus was an example of
the philosophical paradox revolving
around the persistence of identity how
can every single part of something be
replaced yet it still remains the same
thing let's imagine there are two ships
the ship that Theseus docked in Athens
ship a and the ship sailed by the
Athenians a thousand years later ship B
very simply our question is this does a
equal B some would say that for 1,000
years there has been only one ship of
theseus and because the changes made to
it happened gradually it never at any
point in time stopped being the
legendary ship though they have
absolutely no parts in common the two
ships are numerically identical meaning
one and the same so a equals B however
others could argue that Theseus never
set foot on ship B and his presence on
the ship is an essential qualitative
property of the Ship of Theseus it
cannot survive without him so though the
two ships are numerically identical they
are not qualitatively identical thus he
does not
but what happens when we consider this
twist what if as each piece of the
original ship was cast off somebody
collected them all and rebuilt the
entire original ship when it was
finished undeniably to physical ships
would exist
the one that's docked in Athens and the
one in some guys backyard each could lay
claim to the title the Ship of Theseus
but only one could actually be the real
thing
so which one is it and more importantly
what does this have to do with you like
the Ship of Theseus you are a collection
of constantly changing parts your
physical body mind emotions
circumstances and even your quirks
always changing but still in an amazing
and sometimes illogical way you stay the
same - this is one of the reasons that
the question Who am I is so complex and
in order to answer it like so many great
minds before you you must be willing to
dive into the bottomless ocean of
philosophical paradox or maybe you could
just answer I am a legendary hero saving
a powerful ship on an epic journey that
could work too
[Music]
you